and finally new rule and this one's for
Trump voters if you think you hate the
establishment now wait until he wins and
the Trump surrogates that basket of
inexplicable he sends out every day to
speak for him
become the establishment wait until
Steve Cortes and Katrina Pierson and
Chris Christie and amarosa are trundling
down the corridors of power bumping into
the walls we're thinking of giving these
people the reins of power
I wouldn't put them on the bus without
asking the driver to make sure they
don't miss their stop
so in examining all of Donald Trump
surrogates it's very helpful to remember
that Trump actually once said this
always be around unsuccessful people
because everybody will respect you do
you understand that well it does explain
Rudy Giuliani
Rudy Guiliani who claims America never
had a problem with terror attacks until
Obama came along really you can't even
think of one I'll give you a hint Rudy
you make your living off of it Donald
Trump also once said sometimes people
will come into my office no look great
sound great dress beautifully everything
is great then after you hire then they
turn out to be morons which explains his
sons Uday and Cusack
I mean Trump senior in the White House
is bad enough without these two American
psychos putting putting plastic over the
furniture so they can accent or
prostitutes while discussing Phil
Collins and how about the
non-professionals have you seen Pastor
Mark burns he's the pastor who gave the
benediction at the Republican convention
and I'm not saying he's a total
charlatan it's possible that the free
vial of holy oil available from his web
site can cure the sick and if not you
can always use it as righteous Lube but
but he does seem to have lied about
everything
again the bio that's on your website
claims that you you earned a Bachelor of
Science degree did you make that clean I
asked you just a moment ago as we were
just open up this first of all I said we
were off the record I didn't agree to
that yeah but I did I did did you catch
that the interviewer says I didn't agree
this was off the record and he says yeah
but I did right what do you think for
him Secretary of State maybe head of
NASA perhaps
another familiar face on CNN for the
Trump campaign is Marco Gutierrez a
leader of trumps Hispanic Advisory
Council and quite a spokesman for his
peeps he is
he once said my culture is very dominant
culture and it's causing problems if you
don't do something about it
you're gonna have a taco truck on every
corner okay first of all would that be
such a bad thing
you mean when I'm drunk I don't have to
wander around LA looking for a taco
truck that's the best argument for
Hillary I've heard yet but beyond that
mr. Gutierrez is a real estate scam
artist who's filed for bankruptcy 14
times he's not just a Latino for Trump
he's a Latino Trump
then there's a little Kaylee mcenany a
kind of an Coulter without the empathy
and another young woman defending Trump
campaign spokesman someone's crazy
ex-girlfriend sorry I mean Katrina
Pierson who wears a necklace made out of
bullets from the Chanel don't tread on
me collection and once defended it by
tweeting maybe I'll wear a fetus next
time about about Trump's proposed Muslim
ban she said you know what so what
they're Muslim Hey in 2012 she tweeted
perfect Obama's dad born in Africa Mitt
Romney's dad born in Mexico any pure
breeds left big pure breeds where do you
study you're talking points by the light
from a burning cross
she also blames Obama for launching the
war in Afghanistan even though it was
four years before he was even in the
Senate and has said about nuclear
weapons what good is having them if
you're not gonna use them if this were
the hundred thousand dollar pyramid I'd
say things a mental patient what do you
think ambassador the UN for her but I
have to say that of all the surrogates
my favorite has to be mr. Michael Cohen
just just take a look at him in action
on CNN but you guys are down and it
makes us hope that there would socials
most of them all of them says who
holes I just told you I answered your
question okay
which polls all of them
[Applause]
well-played sir
and he's a lawyer in fact he's the head
lawyer at the Trump Organization so we
know he's awfully busy with lawsuits
like the one Trump filed against me in
2013 remember that lawsuit okay a lot of
people remember it as a defamation
defamation so it wasn't he was suing me
to collect five million dollars because
I offered that to him if he could prove
that his mother didn't in fact [ __ ] and
so he went into court this happened he
went into court and produced his birth
certificate as if it was gonna say
orangutan ah yes I made Donald Trump
produce his birth certificate I'm very
sad
[Applause]